today on the matt wall show the trans
age adult baby community cries out for
acceptance on what basis can our culture
deny them also big fat booty gate takes
more twists and turns it's been revealed
that aoc called the cops five times on
the comedian who commented on her latinx
booty plus confidence in the education
system has fallen to a historic low
which is good news and parents throw a
gender reveal party for their
eight-year-old child finally in our
daily cancellation gwen stefani is the
latest white chick to offend the
cultural appropriation police we'll talk
about all that and more today on the
matt wells show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did you know that poor sleep can cause
weight gain mood issues poor mental
health and lower productivity and that
some reports say sleeping less than six
to seven hours per night is linked to
reduce white blood cell count white
blood cells protect our body against
illness and disease fighting viruses
bacteria and more not many people
realize this but having a consistent
nighttime routine is extremely important
that's why a better tomorrow starts
tonight that's why you need to try beam
dream beam is one of the world's most
innovative functional wellness brands
with unique products for everything from
sleep to focus and today my listeners
get a special discount available for
beam's sleep product dream powder it's
their best selling hot cocoa
90 of people surveyed fall asleep faster
when taking beam dream and 99 of people
experience better quality sleep as well
just mix beam dream into hot water or
milk stir
and enjoy before bedtime also beam just
launched a brand new delicious new
summer flavor of dream powder which is
sea salt caramel excuse all caramel
dream powder tastes just like the
caramel drizzle on your summer ice cream
cone but with only 15 calories and you
get better sleep in the bargain better
sleep has never tasted better don't love
it get your money back guaranteed but i
think you will love it i know i did for
a limited time get up to 35 off when you
go to beam organics dot com slash walsh
and use code wall should check out
that's b e a m organics dot com slash
walsh and use code walls for up to 35
percent off
always on top of the important news the
new york post has a report this week
about 28 year old cyber security analyst
lucy who according to the headline
identifies as a proud adult baby who
wears diapers
though lucy cautions that her proclivity
is certainly not a sex fetish it's not
that at all at all she says sure it is
lucy whatever you say
now this article on the one hand falls
squarely into the
sideshow circus category in accordance
with a long tradition stretching back
centuries of traveling freak shows where
onlookers are invited to come and gawk
at all the weirdos
these shows have taken on different
forms over the years and these days they
take the form of
journalism but
on the other hand there are actually
some important lessons to be gleaned
from lucy's story if you can believe it
we are living inside of a perpetual
freak show that's our our cultural
identity really and so we can we can
learn something about our own situation
from cases like this i think so the new
york post tells us quote
a 28 year old cyber security analyst has
revealed she loves wearing diapers and
dressing up as an infant and says
there's no shame in her unusual interest
lucy has not disclosed her surname but
is a proud member of the adult baby
diaper lover community and frequently
posts photos of herself wearing the
disposable underwear quote i didn't find
out about adult babies and that they
existed until i was a teenager and i did
some google searching of my own
she told media drum world until then it
never occurred to me that there would be
more people like me
it's not about kink it's about comfort
she defiantly tells haters who label her
a sick fetishist lucy holds down a
regular white-collar job and has a
normal love life but cruel trolls have
told her that her former boyfriends must
be pedophiles if they're dating a woman
who wears diapers and sucks on
pacifiers well they might not be
pedophiles legally
might not be emphasis on might but
one might argue that there are that they
are pedophiles in spirit at the very
least we learn more quote lucy says her
interest in wearing diapers began after
her baby sister was born i was eight or
nine years old when i first got these
feelings and it was very confusing she
explained the blonde started stealing
her sister's diapers and wearing them
for comfort although she rarely relieved
herself in them we are assured lucy has
found support from others in the addl
community and shares snaps of herself
dressed as a baby on instagram
now
if you're
paying close attention and i wouldn't
blame you if you weren't
this may all sound
eerily familiar and i don't just mean
familiar in the sense that there are
many adult babies in america today even
if most of them don't identify as such i
mean familiar in that lucy sounds
exactly like
other communities of people
who identify as something other than
what they are
just like the
gender identity brigade she says that
she discovered this truth about herself
when she was a child
she says that living this way makes her
feel more at home and at peace with
herself
she denies that it's a sexual fetish
just as
um
men who wear women's clothes deny that
it's a fetish
even though in both cases it has the
appearance and all the hallmarks of a
sexual fetish she even discovered her
own community with its own acronyms
letters that um have not been accepted
under the lgbt umbrella yet but will be
soon enough we can be sure
in fact the trans age community
has a greater claim to validity and
acceptance than the transgender
community age after all does actually
change over time
um it is fluid in that way
and
unlike a man who says he's a woman an
adult who says that they feel like a
child can speak with some measure of
authority on the matter because
they were once a child and therefore
know what it's like to be a child
because they were one once now that
doesn't mean that trans ageism is
actually valid of course it's still
totally deranged and the only community
that such people should share should be
found inside of a mental hospital
but
the point is simply that we as a culture
have already accepted and tolerated and
legitimized
self-identifications even more baseless
outlandish
and incoherent than this
the adult baby is downright
tame and traditional compared to the
life choices we already celebrate and
throw parades for
that's why these various other
communities of fetishists in denial
are are not really the sideshow circus
that we want them to be
the
trans age people the trans species
people
furries the so-called neo pronoun users
people who identify as clouds and trees
and space aliens and so on
along with the uh polyamorous throuples
and the objectum sexuals who wish to be
bonded in wedded bliss with buildings
and bridges and all that
and the whole bizarre assortment of
countless other categories of weirdos
and mutants
these are not
fringe aberrations but rather they are a
gathering flood pressing against a dam
that cannot hold
as a society we no longer have the
language or the basis
for denying the validity of any
alternative lifestyle no matter how
perverse it is all of these communities
to include most especially
the pedophiles who've already helpfully
been rebranded as minor attracted
persons maps quote unquote
all of them
can stake their claim to acceptance
using all of the same arguments and all
the same buzzwords and catchphrases that
have already won the day
culturally speaking
this is the point of the slippery slope
argument which is fallaciously written
off as a fallacy by people who would
prefer for us to be surprised by what
comes next they don't want us to predict
it
but in fact the slippery slope is not
really a prediction uh or a guess or a
theory even less it is it a prophecy
it's actually just an observation
about things that are happening right
now we observe
that the justifications offered on
behalf of one thing
could just as easily be applied to these
dozens of other things that already
exist
and so
if we accept the first thing then we've
already accepted all of those other
things
whether whether we meant to or not
that's the silpery sub
one other point about this as always
you know it'd be impossible to overstate
the effect of the internet and social
media here because a question that often
comes up
and that i get asked a lot is is is uh
you know whether i think that all of
these perversions
which have been normalized in our
culture
did they exist in the past
um but most people simply never heard
about them or
or have we
invented them
in modern times i think the answer to
that is yes and no
the human mind
since the fall of man
has been a dark and twisted place that
was as much the case a hundred years ago
and a thousand years ago
as it is today
the difference
is that prior to the internet
and modern media a person with one of
these sorts of proclivities
would have nowhere safe to go to explore
it anonymously and without fear of
public shame
they would then have no choice but to
suppress it to try to overcome it
to try to live a life in spite of it
ignore it whatever it is and often they
were successful not always but often
but today a person can plumb the depths
of their own
psyche
identify all the weirdest and most
objectionable aspects of themselves and
after a quick google search as we heard
from lucy there
find communities of other people who
share this exact same kind of
psychological disturbance
and then they can then feed and foster
what people in the past would have
suppressed and they could do it with the
cloak of anonymity until they're ready
to announce themselves to the world
and then when that time comes
they know that they'll be accepted and
celebrated
just so long as they show pride
they have to show pride in it
because the only thing they can do wrong
where this proclivity is concerned
or where any lifestyle quote unquote
lifestyle choice is concerned
is to publicly betray any shame or
embarrassment about it
that's the one thing you can't do
because these days in our culture
shame
is really the only sin
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well if you like skydiving that's great
um but make sure you get your will
finalized and then go st skydiving it's
just a fact 100 of people who skydive
will die and in fact it's even worse
than that 100 percent of people who do
anything will die we're all going to die
you don't have a skydive you know to do
you know extremely risky things on
purpose to die you're just you're going
to die we're all going to die any moment
your death is waiting and lurking around
the corner and it will devour you
as you absolve into nothingness so
whether you're going out with a bang or
a skydiving or or you're going to live
another 100 years a will isn't about you
it's about your loved ones about the
really hard decisions they need to make
if something happens to you don't make
your family make hard decisions when all
they should be focused on is grieving
instead give them all the answers like
life support or pull the plug bury your
cremated whatever it is
you need to have all that ready to go
but here's the deal the judge that uh
that might might take over is not gonna
know who your best friend is or who you
trust to raise your kids the fact is a
will is something that can take as
little as five minutes to set up and if
you don't do it you're acting selfishly
so go to epicwheel.com use promo code
walsh and i'll even save you 10
uh while you do it so i mean come on you
can literally have a comprehensive will
starting at 119 and if you don't have a
will your gift wrapping money to the
state by letting the state use its will
its own will to decide everything for
you don't do that don't trust the state
to make any decision for your family go
to epicwheel.com use promo code walsh
and just get it done
all right so um still
enjoying time out here uh on on the lake
in my off hours at least and uh i posted
this picture yesterday this is me
indoctrinating my two-year-old uh
teaching her how to fish she knows how
to she knows how to fish now she knows
how to bait a hook uh with a worm i
taught her that though she kept she kept
wanting to name all of the worms before
we stabbed them and fed them to fish
which was a little bit awkward and
uncomfortable
and of course i um
i posted this picture you know
which is always a mistake and
into twitter and it's it's the internet
so you know i had a bunch of first bunch
of dorks responding actually did you
know she's holding the reel upside down
yeah i did know that she's two okay
that's how she wanted to hold it one
step at a time and all these other
people making various critiques and
observations well why is she wearing a
life vest or she's wearing what the life
vest needs to be tight she's not wearing
it right
and then people who somehow made this
moment with my daughter
political
and there are a lot of comments like
this i love this one from a feminist who
said will matt allow his daughter to go
to college develop a career be a girl
boss
as a man who promotes rigid gender
stereotypes for women expects women to
perform
femininity much like trans ideologues
will he impose those stereotypes on his
daughter
now first of all answer to that i will
absolutely
strongly
discourage my daughter from going to
college and i also discourage my other
daughter and also my my my son though i
discourage all of my kids i greatly
discourage them from going to college so
i will answer that in the affirmative
for you and i also i pray to god that
i'm not raising the kinds of girls
who become the kinds of women who would
describe themselves as girl bosses
as for expecting my daughters to be
feminine yes again i i guilt i'm guilty
as charged that's actually i
you know i want my daughters to grow up
in their femininity i want my boys to
grow up in their masculinity
um i can't teach femininity to my
daughter that's my wife's job but yeah
that is that is my hope for them
i don't know how rigid i really am about
that given that i'm teaching my
two-year-old daughter how to bait a hook
and
catch fish anyway this is the internet
this is what
this is what you get i suppose all right
here's an update on big booty gate now
just to recap uh this important news
story really very briefly
you remember yesterday
a comedian
heckling
aoc as she was
walking into the capitol building
and performing his own his own mini
insurrection
by
pointing out
you know her big booty let's just watch
that video again
aoc my favorite big booty latina i love
you aoc you're my favorite
she wants to kill babies but she's still
beautiful you look very beautiful in
that dress you look very sexy look at
that booty on aoc that's my favorite big
booty latina
i love it my favorite aoc nice to meet
you look how sexy she looks in that
dress
i love it aoc
hot like a tamale
okay so there was
that was that now we've refreshed our
memory
uh making
making someone say
valid observations and uh
uh aoc
at first walks over and looks like she's
kind of playing along and she likes the
attention but then later she says that
actually she was going over to deck the
guy but then decided not to because she
didn't want to catch a case but she
would have just leveled him because we
know that when you see aoc you know she
knows how to throw a punch right that's
the first thing you think you think this
is a tough person knows how to throw a
punch
well um some updates to this to this uh
breaking news story we learned last
night
according according to journalist sarah
faris who reported says inside capital
just now representative aoc
asked to speak with female and lgbt
reporters to warn us that the man who
harassed her is affiliated with
credentialed news outlets she said her
staff called capitol police five times
to get them to do something
so she actually
called the police now we we know that in
her tweets about it
when originally she said she didn't want
to call any attention to this and then
she decided that
she was going to call attention she
didn't want to call attention to the guy
alex stein but then she decided to
because she realized that uh well
calling attention to him means calling
attention to me you know and she wanted
to call attention to herself but she
said that she expected
the police to get involved she doesn't
know why he was allowed to do this that
is why was he allowed to speak to her in
a way that she didn't like that should
be against the law uh she he shouldn't
have free speech when speaking to her
what's her point but we didn't know that
she actually could did call the police
not just on through a tweet but actually
called them five times
to
to demand what it's not exactly clear
that you want to go cart this guy away
in cuffs because i wish i could have
heard that conversation the first time
she called and talked to the capitol
police
i wanna i wish i could be a fly on the
wall for that conversation
reporting
oh yeah you need to get rid of this guy
oh what do you do um he said i have a
big booty that's what he did
and meanwhile remember that she has um
you know the capitol police
might not be
overly eager to help her
especially in this case because there's
nothing they can do the guy didn't break
the law
but she also has thrown the capitol
police under the bus many times after
january 6th
you remember her harrowing story of
being in an adjacent building when
people were trespassing in in not in her
building but in a building next door
and how her life was flashing before
eyes it was a it was a it was a
life-threatening moment for her
but then she remember tells the story of
a capital police officer coming in
to get her to safety even though she
never her safety was never really in
jeopardy but then she talks about how
she feared the capitol police officer
feared that he that he would act out
violently against her like this guy came
in to
by her telling save her life
and he throws her right at the she
throws him right under the bus
so called the police nothing happened
there
and then another development um
she
before tweeting about it and calling the
police she posted an instagram video
which she then deleted
but the internet is forever so we have
now the video that she first posted
before the video of the actual incident
went viral here's what she posted
immediately afterwards telling her
instagram followers about it and here
was her version of events
before everyone else had actually seen
it for themselves here it is
hey everybody i'm here in the capitol um
see this guy right there
right there
he when i was walking up
um
he said hey
right in front of a capitol police
officer see my favorite big booty latina
i love you aoc you're my favorite hey
uh
here's this look at that big ass look at
that big juicy booty this latina like
whatever you know all the bunch of
racist sexist stuff and since
nobody can do anything she wants to kill
babies but she's still beautiful
i'm just telling you because
this institution is not designed to
protect
people look at that booty on aoc that's
my favorite big booty latina and it's
really hard and it's really sad that my
only recourse
is to just let you know about it but
that's the institution we're in
i love it aoc
hot like a tamale
okay so that's what she deleted that but
like we said the internet's forever so
it's out there
uh there there
is a few great aspects of this
one is that
she adds
she adds additional descriptions of her
booty that were never actually used
so she said she claims that her booty
was described as as juicy and that
you know we need to snope fact check on
that because that was never said like
that's how she's describing herself
and then putting that in the words in
the into the mouth of uh
well that's unfortunate phrasing uh
that's how she gets discovered cut that
out that's how she's choosing to
describe herself
uh this this is the kind of narcissism
that this woman has that even in the
context of uh complaining she's
practically in tears about this
and saying that her you know her safety
was jeopardized claiming she was
sexually harassed but she still adds
additional i suppose they're supposed to
be flattering descriptions of herself
that were not said
um this is a
another juicy sommelier she's putting
the juicy and juicy here i suppose
uh but then she also she she says that
this institution talking about congress
well it's apparently not designed to
protect
people and she really means me
apparently it's not designed to protect
me
well right of course
what what institution do you think
you're a part of
the institution is designed to you're in
the legislative branch it's designed to
to write legislation to pass laws
it's not designed
with the primary
function of protecting you
not at all actually
and even through all of this she never
explains what exactly
she expects the police to do she just
wants them that's what we always get
from the left right do something they
have to do something what do you want
them do you actually think this guy
should be carted away in handcuffs and
thrown in prison
for
describing your booty in ways that you
didn't approve of is that actually what
what is the crime what crime do you
think they're going to charge him with
well of course she doesn't have to
explain that she she has her emotions
that's all that matters
she is as she put it i'm morally correct
but if not factually correct
all right moving on uh more house
hearings on so-called abortion rights
yesterday this one focusing less on
pregnant men and more on i suppose the
actual issue at hand finally after three
or four days of hearings we've actually
gotten to the to the issue right of
abortion and all of that so here's one
exchange between representative chip roy
and a pro-abortion witness
over something that really matters here
in this conversation which is when
exactly does life begin and let's see
how that goes
who as a matter of law is
who decides when life begins and who
decides when and how life is protected
the constitution does not speak to the
question of when life begins just that
it doesn't speak to many other things
including the right to an abortion and
executive privilege and qualified
immunity
specifically saying when life begins
then who best to decide
when to protect life the people or
courts
representative roy as you know the
question of when life begins is a
personal question informed by religious
beliefs our constitution in the very
first amendment says emphatically that
the government shall not endorse any
particular religion it shall not
professor professor when we have life
when we just make decisions about
protecting life which we do all the time
if if a three-month-old infant
is murdered
we protect that life if
a 50-year-old is murdered we have laws
across the country that protect that
life we make decisions about when life
begins my simple question is as a matter
of law
is when who decides when we protect life
and whether or not that is judges to
decide that moment or whether that is
elected representatives elected by the
people
well representative roy as you say we
have laws those laws are written by our
representatives we also have fundamental
rights and as you have noted these
fundamental rights are not unfettered
but they do allow individuals to possess
certain freedoms for example the second
amendment right despite the fact that we
have prohibitions on murder allow
individuals to bear arms indeed
sometimes to effects that are incredibly
deleterious
we have fundamental rights but one of
the fundamental rights is not the right
to life apparently um
that's that you would think that would
be the most fundamental right of all
that would be the right that all other
rights
are grounded in because you can't have
the right to do anything if you don't
exist
if you don't have a fundamental right to
exist then how could you have the right
to do anything
in particular once you do exist doesn't
make a lot of sense
you know
the the left will say well you have a
right to make reproductive decisions
obviously abortion has nothing to do
with with making a reproductive decision
but that's the way they frame it well
how would you even have that right if
you don't have the right to to exist to
begin with if you have no right to exist
on this planet if you have no right to
the very
life that you've been granted
by god then uh then
within that life and the choices they
make how do you have a right to any of
that it doesn't make any sense at all
she also says that that um
it is a personal question the question
of when life begins
is a personal question informed by
religious beliefs
well no
see
it is your
personal religious belief
that it's a personal religious belief
um
when life begins that that is you you
categorizing the whole question of when
life begins as a personal religious
belief is your personal religious belief
um as you're a member of the the
religion of leftism
but in reality looked at objectively
it's not a religious question at all and
it's not really a personal question
it's certainly not personal in the sense
of being subjective
each person can come up with their own
answer but there is a right answer and a
wrong answer
so when life begins is a biological
scientific
question
and it has to be that
because if it were merely subjective
then there's no way for any then no one
can be right about it
which means that um
you know if it's if it's totally
subjective
then when i say that life begins a
conception i'm not objectively right
but then again when pro-abortion people
say that it doesn't begin a conception
they're also not right nobody's right
and nobody can claim to be right then
but no this is an objective question
the definition of of life is a
biological question
you go to biology you have a biology
textbook and they will define what life
is
and then you take that definition and
see if it applies to a human being at
its earliest stages and the answer is of
course it does
other witnesses were speaking out about
the terrible evils of pregnancy centers
listen to this
first challenge just one of the
misleading talking points that our
colleagues across the island their
witness have been pushing today
that the existence of pregnancy crisis
care centers is somehow evidence that
the anti-abortion movement actually
cares about mothers and families
it's just not true
in fact these crisis pregnancy centers
are a well-funded arm of the
anti-abortion movement that advances
their agenda by using deceptive and
coercive tactics and medical
disinformation to target low-income
people facing unintended pregnancies to
prevent them from accessing abortion and
contraception
these crisis pregnancy centers which
actually outnumber abortion clinics
often misleadingly present themselves as
providing medical services when they're
not licensed to do so and therefore are
not bound by the privacy laws that
govern medical providers and in fact
these anti-abortion facilities collect
sensitive medical and personal
information and then share it with
anti-abortion organizations
these crisis pregnancy centers face
limited public accountability despite
the fact that they are increasingly
siphoning off public funds from the tanf
welfare programs which are supposed to
serve low-income women and families
uh so that was representative mary gay
scanlon of pennsylvania
doing the thing that we've we've heard
now from the democrats repeatedly since
roe v wade was overturned demonizing
pregnancy centers elizabeth warren a
couple days ago was
singing the same tune
let's listen to that
in massachusetts right now
those
crisis pregnancy centers
that are there
to fool people who are looking for
pregnancy termination help
outnumber
true abortion clinics by three to one
we need to shut them down here in
massachusetts and we need to shut them
down all around the country
you should not be able
to torture a pregnant person like that
this woman is such a demon she really is
a she's a demon in the
flesh uh
you're torturing a pregnant person she
says because i want to say woman
you're torturing a pregnant man or woman
by providing them with food and diapers
and baby clothes and counseling and
uh
medical treatment and medical referrals
and all kinds of other things
i mean there's really no there's really
no
limit the only limitation with pregnancy
centers the only limitation in the kind
of services that they can provide to
women it's is a matter of fundraising
and pregnancy centers are not they don't
get billions of dollars
of taxpayer funding like the abortion
clinics do like planned parenthood does
the pregnancy centers are not a
multi-billion dollar enterprise
like the abortion clinics are
in the abortion industry overall
so the only limitation is just in the is
in is in their own resources how much
money they have
but when they're well funded they they
can provide i mean there there have been
pregnancy centers that have uh
teamed together as a community and
helped to build houses for for pregnant
women i mean they've done all kinds of
things
the only thing
that they won't do
for a pregnant woman is kill the woman's
child
okay because that's not that's not
something that you do for
that's that's not that's actually not a
that's not a real true service
that's something that you inflict on on
a woman
and she ultimately becomes a victim of
it as well even if she
is choosing it and thinks it's the right
thing eventually
she's going to realize it wasn't she's
going to live with that guilt for the
rest of her life
but you notice the way she she puts it
elizabeth warren says um
well these pregnancy centers they
outnumber true abortion clinics three to
one what do you mean true abortion
clinics
well these pregnancies they're not true
abortion clinics yeah they never claim
to be
because elizabeth warren cannot even
conceive of a
of any sort of clinic or center
that exists to serve pregnant women and
yet doesn't
it doesn't center its business around
killing the baby
for her the the two things are
inextricably linked
but the only true service for a pregnant
woman is to make her unpregnant
violently
by killing the child and discarding it
in a medical waste dumpster
she can't she can't
conceive of it any other way
you know one of the left's favorite
tactics is to say that you can't speak
on any subject until you've met and
spoken to people in the community you're
talking about
so of course if you disagree with them
about gender theory then they assume
that it's because you've never talked to
a trans person you've heard that many
times i get it all the time
any time i talk about this issue oh you
you need to sit down and talk to a trans
person well um famously now i have sat
down and talked to a number of trans
people and actually after talking to
them i disagree with gender theory even
more after talking to them
but
but here's a case with pregnancy centers
where it might actually help to meet and
talk to the people you're talking about
because the way that these democrats
talk about women and men who work at
pregnancy centers they
they paint them as these deceptive
sinister plotting conniving villains who
don't actually care we heard a bit from
the first democrat there in the first
clip they don't actually care about
women at all they're just they only care
about their pro their anti-abortion
agenda
well
you know if you go and actually meet
these people as i have i've met
and talked to hundreds of people at work
at pregnancy centers i've i've i've
given speeches at
dozens and dozens and dozens of um
pregnancy center
fundraisers over the years i've attended
marches and rallies and other events
with people that work
um in this field
and they are i mean truly
the
the nicest people you'll
ever meet
just the nicest people
because they have to be there's there's
no money in this again it's not like the
abortion industry
where you can make a lot of money the
abortion doctors they make a lot of
money abortionists i should say
it's a lot of money in it
uh the people running planned parenthood
make millions of dollars
but in running a pregnancy center you're
not you're not going to enrich yourself
you're going to be
almost as poor as the women you're
helping
if not as poor as them and um
and you've you've given your life to
simply serving women in need
you have to be a nice caring person to
do that
if you have sinister motivations you
wouldn't survive you wouldn't survive in
this in this field
doing this every single day
it's just uh completely absurd all right
here's some good news for you on a
friday we could all use some good news
it says americans confidence in the u.s
public school system has fallen nearly
to an all-time low of 26 percent
recorded in
2014 according to a poll released
thursday that also found the gap between
the faith democrats and republicans
having the system has expanded overall
28 of americans say they have a great
deal or quite a lot of confidence in the
country's school systems
barely beating the record low from 2014.
uh trust has been on a downward slide
since it hit a high of 62 percent in
1975 but rebounded slightly to 41
in 2020 so how for how long
have a majority of americans distrusted
the public school system
we were at 62
in 1975
when did it dip below majority we don't
have that exactly here but i think we
can assume that for decades that's been
the case
the rate then plummeted to 32 in 2021 at
28
in 2022 survey also indicated the stark
political divide between parties with 43
democrats saying they have confidence in
the system compared to only 14 percent
of republicans among independents that
rate is at 29 percent
uh but even for democrats it's still
still pretty low
so that's the good news
okay
now it's not good that we have an
education system
which
deserves so little of our trust
but given that we do have that education
it's good that people have noticed it
that's the good part
the bad news though is
okay 28 of americans
only 28 of americans have faith or trust
in the school system
well i went and checked the figures
85 to 90
of american kids are still in
the public school system
so i'm trying to figure that out
only 28
trust it but then 90 percent of our kids
are still in the system
which means that you've got millions of
american families
it would seem to suggest
who don't trust the system
and yet still send their kids into it
and don't trust it
like i know i i know all the excuses and
i always add the disclaimers that uh
that there are there are people who
legitimately cannot make the decision
right now this moment to abandon the
public school system they're just they
they they can't do it
um for financial reasons for other kinds
of reasons
but there are a lot of people
who could make that decision right away
and uh
and don't because because of the
sacrifices it would require
and we just have to decide like what's
most important to us if you
you know the fact that we have an
education system
that is decaying
that is totally corrupted from the
ground up
that is a big
problem
the fact that the vast majority of
americans do not trust the education
system the system that educates our
children that shapes and forms
our children
the fact that nobody trusts it is a huge
problem well if you want to solve a huge
problem it requires major sacrifices it
just does
and you have to be willing to do
bold
uh
things that might seem even a little bit
crazy and for a lot of people you're so
used to you kind of grow up in this
system you're in public school it's just
what everyone does the idea of getting
out of that system homeschooling looking
for alternatives it seems crazy for a
lot well
it's not crazy but even if it seems that
way to you
you have to be willing to do things like
that radical things if we want to solve
a problem of this magnitude
there's just no
other way around it all right let's see
what else do we have here
um
[Music]
okay i wanted to talk about this we
don't have a lot of time for it but
maybe we'll revisit it next week this is
from the mirror it says nikki and graham
scott's gender reveal party started out
like any other the couple from ontario
canada celebrated the momentous occasion
as they revealed the gender of their
baby to wider family
but their child wasn't a tiny tot yet to
be born the party was
for their eight-year-old daughter after
quote unquote she told them she no
longer wanted to live as a boy ella
scott eight first told her parents that
she didn't feel like a boy
inside when she was six
and then they decided to throw this big
public gender reveal party
gender reveal announcing their uh
their child's quote-unquote new gender
to the world and
this is what parents do
as we always talk about
as a it's yes it's virtue signaling okay
yes they're using their kids as fashion
accessories and pawns to signal their
own virtue to the world
but also there's a there's an actual
strategy behind it and what they're what
they're looking to do is
is a lock
as much as they claim
that they want their child to be able to
explore freely and make all free
decisions now what they're doing is
they're locking their child down in that
false identity
by making it into a public spectacle
i mean what
how else is the child supposed to
interpret that you've thrown a party
invited all family and friends you've
announced it on you've gone to the media
and told everybody about it
now you've put all this pressure on your
child on purpose saying
this is who you are now
if you change your mind that's going to
be very embarrassing and disappointing
for lots of people so you can't change
your mind
you're stuck with this
that's the strategy behind it now
i i checked on youtube to see if this
interview was available there so i could
play it rather than read it and i didn't
find it but i did find something else um
that very much related to this
this is an apparently prominent youtube
youtuber youtube family it's got 1.7
million subscribers i know i'm gonna
mispronounce the name i don't know how
i'm supposed to announce this um
sakon jolies i don't know
s-a-c-c-o-n-e-j-o-l-y-s
that's that's the channel and it's this
family uh apparently mother and father
and they've kind of like raised their
kids on youtube and they've been
exploiting their kids for for youtube
fame for a long time well just a couple
of weeks ago the reason that this popped
up when i was looking for this other
interview is that they unveiled their
own trans eight-year-old and i wanted to
show you
uh a little bit of this video watch this
hey guys welcome to our video
today i thought we would do something
fun don't mind the fact that edie now
looks fabulous okay because in between
making this video we actually shot tick
tock where we straighten the hair this
is my first time ever straightening hair
by the way can i can i can we get some
can we get some like applauses here
i did a pretty good job right
you say yes father that is the best hair
straightening i've ever seen she's also
wearing lashes
oh my goodness oh my goodness anyway
we thought we would make a video because
so many people have been asking us and
to talk about all the other names that
edie um did not use
uh when she was changing her name to eat
delicious she is officially it's e
delicious but shortened
it's not it's just eating but we decided
we'd make a video yeah
and
i thought it would be better if edie
made the video so in her own words she's
going to tell you guys bring you on a
journey
a journey
okay
so their son uh now quote unquote
identifies as a girl with the name e
delicious and as you can see there in
the video this uh father and i use that
term
only in the biological dictionary
definition sense of the term and no
others
um
this father is uh
holding his son up in front of camera
you know wearing makeup and false
eyelashes
hair hair grown out straighten the hair
so this father
has dolled up his own son as a girl
and is now
just literally holding him up in front
of the camera saying look at this look
what i got
here's the point to make about this i've
made many points about it in the past
but this is um
this is abuse obviously yes but this is
sexual abuse of a child and i really
think we need to start
putting it that way and being specific
in that way
because when you just say well this is
abusive towards a child that should be
enough for people right that should
carry enough power
um because any kind of abuse is horrific
when inflicted on a child
but but i think it needs it needs more
specificity we need to be more specific
in the charge
that we are
making
so this is this is in fact a form of
sexual abuse of a child
and the parents that do this to their
kids
that cross-dress their kids
and give them these false sexual
identities
especially dress up their sons and
makeup and false eyelashes that would be
inappropriate for a girl of that age
i mean how weird would it be if that was
an actual girl and the father was
holding her up in front of camera look i
gave her look i did her hair and i gave
her false eyelashes i mean how weird
would that be weird is an understatement
so this is the sexual abuse of a child
the people that do this are sexual
abusers of their own kids that's what we
need to say because it's true
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
you notice uh when stores are trying to
sell products that they know next to
nothing about maybe they push the shoes
that are most popular rather than the
ones that actually fit your feet well
i like rockauto.com because what they
know is auto parts and all they sell is
auto parts and all the related tools
rock auto is a family business founded
by automotive engineers engineers over
20 years ago their original goal was and
still is to make auto parts available
and affordable so customers can keep
their daily drivers and classics safely
on the road rockauto.com's online parts
catalog is uniquely easy to navigate
you quickly see all the parts available
for your specific car suv or truck there
are photos specs and installation tips
to help you pick the best parts to meet
your vehicle's needs so it's very easy
for you and very affordable rockauto.com
will not only have the part but usually
they're going to give you several
trusted brands to choose from huge
selection with rockauto.com and their
kits are also popular because they
bundle together all the parts needed for
successful repair you don't get halfway
through installing a timing belt and
discover you need another pulley or
something like that all you got to do is
go to rockauto.com
get the brakes shocks carpets wipers
headlights mirrors mufflers lug nuts or
any other part you need be sure when you
check out to write walsh in their how
did you hear about us box so they know
that i sent you
eath man says the next matt walsh merch
should be a big booty la tinx badge
i like the idea i need to workshop it a
little bit
i'm not sure
you know usually these badges come with
some kind of image there are lots of
ways we can get ourselves in trouble
with that but you know we'll we'll we'll
work we're always open to suggestions
for the uh for the matt walsh
merchandise storage by the way go to
dailywire.com
shop and find so many great items there
um olu says i subscribe to dw because of
what is a woman only to find out that
your show airs earlier on dw the
schmucks on youtube have to wait for a
whole hour you could have said so and i
would have subscribed way earlier
that's good that's yet another perk and
that's why you should become a daily
wire member is that you can get this
exact content just an hour earlier i
think there are better perks which is
why i usually go with you know the
premium content that sort of thing when
i'm pitching the subscribers but that is
that's also one of them
um brandon says early comment here so
you may mention this later but the
reason the people with the ability to
get pregnant is not a good definition
for women is because of menopause i
don't think an elderly woman should be
considered not a woman
so as i agree with the point you were
making that would be the ideal
definition that would not be the ideal
definition of woman then another comment
agrees says i love matt walsh but
sometimes i think he needs to think
before he speaks
i believe the topic of pregnant men is
disgusting but the fact that walsh said
the ability to get pregnant defines
women
is kinda offensive and rude i mean my
cousin's girlfriend is infertile so that
kinda not a really good thing to say i
get he's trying to be nice but saying
pregnant women are better than women
but
the way he said it is just misleading
also conservatives aren't the only ones
who hate this leftist crap now i wasn't
trying to be nice at all my point i'm
never that's never my
my overarching point is never simply to
be nice okay and especially when we're
talking about the definition of woman
i'm trying to be accurate and yes
defining a woman as a human being with
the capacity to get pregnant that is an
accurate definition
and and yes i am aware
that there are women who are infertile
there are women who have passed
menopause there are women who for
various other reasons can't get pregnant
but that does not
change the fact
that women
are those with the capacity of pregnant
just like
i could say if i was looking to describe
a human being and define a human being
one of the things i would say
is that a human being walks on two legs
okay would anyone object to that would
anyone object to the statement
that a human being walks on two legs
but well no of course you wouldn't
okay because like the point is that we
don't we don't we don't crawl around on
all fours we don't slither on the ground
like a snake we don't fly through the
air we walk on two legs that's an
important defining feature of a human
being
the fact that
well babies can't walk on two legs uh
elderly people sometimes on in
wheelchairs can't
disabled people
cannot walk on two legs
that doesn't change the validity of the
statement
okay because a human being in principle
is
able to walk on two legs
maybe another way you could put it is if
you want to be very specific in your
language a human being is someone
of the nature to walk onto like so you
could say a woman
is someone of the nature to become
pregnant
and the fact that
some women suffer from
illnesses or or simply are are just are
just older and not able to that does not
change that definition
okay because if it does
then you're you've created a situation
where we can't talk about anything right
like we can't describe or talk about
anything because they're always going to
be these exceptions they're always going
to be aberrations
and so you make it impossible to
describe women you make it impossible to
describe human beings you make it like
there's no physical feature of a human
being that everybody or there are very
few anyway uh that that all human beings
share they're almost always going to be
aberrations and disabilities and
deformities whereas you know certain
aspects of um
you know
people suffer from certain things where
they don't they don't share some of
these features
so that's that's the situation you
create
or
you know we can talk about these things
in principle
and we all know what we're trying to say
listen i know it's going to come as a
great shock but the latest overpriced
celebrity-laden blockbuster from netflix
arrived with a dull thud and that's just
one more a long line of duds that
hollywood has produced this summer and
honestly over the last several years
rather than waste this weekend watching
another mediocre production here's a
humble suggestion check out daily wire
plus daily wire plus is everything you
love about the daywire plus so much more
and we're continuing to build our
content library with movies and shows
that are engaging entertaining and
thought provoking uh like for example my
movie what is a woman unlike a hollywood
movie that comes and goes in less time
than it takes to make a trip to the
popcorn stand what is a woman still
holding 97 fresh rating on rotten
tomatoes from over 5 000 reviews then
there's gina carano summer blockbuster
terror on the prairie that will keep you
on the edge of your seat and shows like
fauci unmasked and jordan peterson's new
four-part series dragon monsters and men
imagine that shows and movies that you
actually want to see it's what you get
from daily wire plus it's time to build
the future you want to see and get the
shows you want to see at the exact same
time become a member at
dailywireplus.com
and for a limited time you can get 35
percent off your new membership with
code plus so head to dailywireplus.com
today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well the latest white person to run
afoul of the cultural appropriation
police is gwen stefani the former lead
singer of no doubt is back with a new
single featuring sean paul not to be
confused with john paul the canonized
pope sometimes you get too confused the
former is a jamaican rapper and um the
collaboration between paul and stefani
reflects uh paul's jamaican roots
uh here's a just a quick look at the
music video
take the body ablaze your body your
blades being you baby set your body your
blade set your body your blades your
body
[Music]
can you take me
[Music]
don't do worry don't worry your brain
well there's certainly no question that
it's an objectively terrible song
stefani has yet another pop star in her
50s who's been in the music business for
several decades and yet steadfastly
refuses to grow or evolve at all as an
artist it's almost an achievement in its
own right to do something for 40 years
and not improve
in fact her music today would seem to
have less substance than the stuff that
she was putting out 35 years ago as an
angsty teenager singing breakup songs
but gwen stefani
does not stand accused of making bad
music certainly any court would convict
her on that charge but that's not the
charge instead she's accused of
appropriating
that is stealing from other cultures
sneaking into other cultures in the
middle of the night and committing a
culture heist snatching up musical
sounds and dance moves and hairstyles
that don't belong to her and using these
ill-begotten cultural items for her own
selfish ends that's the accusation this
is not the first time the singer has
faced these kinds of accusations as an
article in usa today explained last year
quote stefani has faced decades of
cultural appropriation accusations from
wearing a bindi a south asian religious
symbol in the 90s to her 2005 luxurious
music video where she imitated hispanic
culture and seductively danced in our
lady of guadalupe shirt
and that seems like appropriating from
catholic culture if anything in 2012
stefani donned native american attire in
no doubt looking hot music video which
depicted a cowboy vs indian fight with
teepees and feathered headdresses
my god the group pulled the video and
apologized for being hurtful and
offensive but the most serious claim of
cultural appropriation came from the
japanese inspired imagery stefani used
heavily on her 2004 album love angel
music baby which birthed her number one
single holla back girl
and her uh harajuku girl's entourage
comedian margaret cho has compared
stefani's girl group of dancers of
japanese descent which frequently
accompanied the pop star in music videos
and red carpet events to a minstrel show
a minstrel show
because she used actual japanese dancers
no minstrel shows mostly featured white
people in blackface mocking black people
so if you want a good example of a
modern minstrel show all you need to do
is look at the footage from any drag
event there you have men and women face
making an overly sexualized gratuitous
and ugly mockery of femininity in
womanhood but as has been established
many times over
uh gay cross dressers and people who
identify as trans are exempt from the
anti-appropriation rules they can steal
pilfer appropriate until they've had
their fill
a man can put on a dress makeup fake
breasts call himself a woman's name and
yet somehow appropriate nothing
but a woman who simply dawns a different
hairstyle is a vicious cultural thief
those are the rules no matter how little
sense they make
now as for the latest appropriation
allegation against stefani newsweek
reports gwen stefani's being accused of
cultural appropriation following the
release of her new music video with sean
paul and shenziyah
quote culture is nothing but dress-up
for you gwen one person wrote it's time
you stop treating people's heritage like
a childish game and give it the respect
it deserves they continued alternatively
why don't you betray your own cultural
background within your work i'm sure
people would love to see that
a second agreed writing heavy sigh
i refuse to believe no one attempted to
explain this to her especially
considering there's been public
discourse about her appropriation so the
conclusion is she's aware she doesn't
give an s
i'm sure her insert other ethnicity's
friends said it's okay
and there are other similar comments now
this is all nonsense of course you would
think that the people who you know love
to see everything as fluid and on a
spectrum and a human construct
would understand that culture is by
definition
the most fluid human construct of all
it's a human construct and it's fluid
culture is is it's simply it's the the
customs the traditions the arts
um institutions of any group of people
and all of those things are evolving
they're in a constant exchange with
other cultures
um
to put it in a very lefty sounding way
cultures are in conversation with each
other
and in this in this era where everybody
is so connected
that process is in hyperdrive this is
why even if it made sense to accuse one
culture of stealing something from
another culture which it doesn't
because theft deprives the victim of the
thing being stolen but nobody's being
prevented from wearing drag dreadlocks
or singing reggae just because gwen
stefani is doing it
but even if that made sense still we
would never be able to identify
who was actually guilty of stealing
stealing from whom
humans have been making culture in some
form or another for tens of thousands of
years
for most trends and fashions it's not
possible to identify a definitive date
uh or place of origin
because any time you think you have it
well this is when this fashion came in
to be well yeah but whoever came up with
that like they were influenced by
something and uh and whoever they were
influenced by was influenced and you
just keep going farther and farther back
it's just it's impossible to come up
with a definitive
beginning
and even if you could
um who cares is the other question even
if you could identify all this stuff
dreadlocks dreadlocks in particular have
a diverse history and have been worn by
people of many different races vikings
or dreadlocks hindus wore them so who
owns them
answer nobody
because style is not a thing that can be
owned
we might as well say that like whoever
uh baked
the first loaf of bread
owns the concept of bread and only the
direct descendants of that person are
allowed to
make bread but even that analogy doesn't
quite capture the absurdity of the
cultural appropriation premise because
bread after all is a solid physical
thing
culture is not
so maybe it's more like claiming that
the first person to ever
feel a certain emotion or experience a
certain mood
now lays claim over that experience and
only his progeny may partake in it
but all this is obvious um i think and
and the people who promote the cultural
appropriation myth certainly already
know it
they know the cultural is a nonsensical
concept which is why it's a standard
that they never apply to themselves
because they know it's an impossible
standard
it's only ever applied to white people
you'll notice that no non-white person
is accused of cultural appropriation
it is a charge ex reserved almost
exclusively for white people
why is that
because it's not about cultural
appropriation
but cultural deprivation
by taking anything a white person says
or does or any art they create
bad art in this case but still
or taking anything they wear or any
style or fashion and whatever it is and
tracing it back through some circuitous
and often partly fictionalized route to
a non-white culture declaring that it's
now off limits for white people the
promoters of this idea are really saying
that white people are not allowed to
have or participate in any sort of
culture at all
just as white people are not allowed to
have uh an identity you know they
certainly aren't allowed to be proud of
their heritage or ancestry all of that
is reserved for non-white people
there was another comment on this um
which was quoted by a yahoo article that
makes this clear the twitter user posted
if gwen stefani proves one thing it's
that caucasian culture as a whole
just isn't anything to get excited about
what's she gonna do build a career
around summer dresses hats and beige
now
i would be slammed as a racist for even
referring to
caucasian culture at all
but a non-white person is allowed to
claim the existence of a white culture
only to degrade it
and limit it to summer dresses and beige
this of course is the real point
cultural appropriation is a
fundamentally and specifically
anti-white invention
and that's why it is
once again not for the first time not
for the last cancelled
and that will do it for us today and the
week we'll talk to you on monday have a
great weekend godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomblin our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show democrats
say they want to speak for minorities
and blue-collar workers but their
politics is instead driven by
college-educated white elites plus aoc
reacts to being trolled by yelling at
the capitol police that's today on the
bench bureau show give it a listen